I wish she really loved you I mean I do
everybody loves their boss first of all
maybe they love me because I don't I
don't act like a bus because I don't
want to be pursue Percy I don't know how
to pretend for say that perceived as the
same as a bus I have a manager and we
all work for our passion what we love we
have people helping us to be the best of
us but I can share things with them but
I'm not gonna be the one to say what's
that
what I'm not like that at all when
something happens to them and I see a
dancer which normally gives me a little
like this and say and that night it she
doesn't or he doesn't right away after
their show I said is everything okay
with you no Kelby or I think okay with
you're not afraid to go there I'm not
afraid to go there and I certainly want
to know you do have a lot of courage I
mean you know being a mom being this
amazing performer if I said to you being
a mom means what what does it mean to
you
the most rewarding thing in the world to
be having the privilege as a woman to
carry a miracle to have a baby being a
daughter means what
being a daughter being lucky to be able
to live that life I think life is
wonderful there's two sides of coins
some people see life as a challenge
difficult and not fair some people see
this as challenge and goals and for you
to just try to go forward and go one
side at a time and make the best of it